Transcription: Florence Ammovilli
Relecteur: Audrey Freudenreich
Êtes-vous capable de dire non
à quelqu’un que vous aimez ?
Êtes-vous capable d’exprimer
vos sentiments, votre opinion,
sans avoir peur des conséquences ?
Si on m’avait posé la question
il y a deux ans,
j’aurais répondu cinq, maximum six.
Parce qu’il y a deux ans, je jouais
au jeu auquel tout le monde joue.
À l'école, il faut être le plus populaire.
Avoir le plus d’amis.
Alors, je suivais les modes
sans jamais me demander
si ça me correspondait réellement.
Ensuite, j’ai poursuivi le jeu du statut
dans le meilleur job,
dans la meilleure boîte.
Parce qu’après tout, c’est comme ça
qu’on détermine si quelqu’un a réussi.
Il faut faire du sport
pour avoir un beau corps.
Il faut faire beaucoup d’argent
pour avoir une grande maison.
C’est un jeu auquel on joue
tous avec les mêmes règles.
On peut déterminer entre quelqu’un
qui a le meilleur résultat,
quelle maison vaut la plus chère.
En revanche, on peut pas déterminer
entre deux personnes
qui est le plus heureux,
qui est le plus aligné avec lui-même.
Parce que c'est une compétition interne.
On va pas chercher
une valorisation extérieure.
La mauvaise nouvelle, c’est que
nous sommes des créatures sociales.
On est programmés et guidés
par la valorisation extérieure.
Le problème, c’est que la vie
c’est un jeu solitaire.
On est seuls, on meurt seuls
et toutes nos interprétations sont seules.
Alors un jour, j’en ai eu marre
de jouer à ce jeu
auquel personne ne gagne vraiment.
Je me suis rendu compte
que je poursuivais des quêtes
juste pour appartenir à un groupe,
quitte à pas être réellement moi-même.
Parce qu’au fond, je savais pas vraiment
ce que ça voulait dire être soi.
Je sais que je m’appelle Mathilde,
j’ai 23 ans, je viens de Normandie,
mais ça, c’est pas vraiment
des choses que j’ai choisies.
Si à l’école on m’a appris
à choisir mon métier,
on m’a jamais demandé
qui je voulais devenir,
qui je voulais être.
J'ai donc voulu le découvrir.
J'ai commencé par déconstruire tout ce
qu'on m'avait appris quand j'étais jeune.
Parce que toute mon enfance
on m’a appris à être adulte,
mais une fois la vingtaine passée,
je me rends compte que
le monde dans lequel on m’a fait vivre
ne fonctionne déjà plus de la même façon.
Alors, on a l’impression de
jamais vraiment être adulte.
Parce qu’être adulte
dans ma tête de petite fille, c’était
avoir un travail stable,
des enfants, une grande maison
et surtout avoir réponse à tout.
Et moi, bah j'ai rien de tout ça.
Tout le monde me disait :
« Mathilde, tu es jeune, tu as le temps. »
« Tu auras le temps plus tard de faire
toutes les choses que tu souhaites. »
Alors, j’attendais que les années passent.
J'attendais que demain sera mieux.
Et un jour, j’en ai eu marre d’attendre.
Parce que j’ai compris que demain
sera pas forcément mieux,
que l’important, c’était maintenant.
Le moment où j’ai décidé
d’arrêter d’attendre,
arrêter de demander la permission,
arrêter de demander l’autorisation
pour partir voyager seule,
pour créer mon entreprise
ou pour prendre la parole publiquement.
En bref, pour être moi-même.
À 21 ans, je suis partie voyager seule
pendant six mois.
J’ai parcouru dix pays
en quête de mon identité.
J’ai commencé par délaisser
tout ce que j’avais :
mes affaires, mon appartement,
mes amis et même ma famille.
Je suis partie sans vraiment
le dire à personne,
à part à ma mère pour
des raisons assez évidentes.
Je voulais pas qu'elle appelle la police.
Et j'ai commencé par l'Europe.
Je suis allée par Amsterdam,
Berlin, Zagreb, Vienne, Venise,
jusqu’à finir à New York.
Et dans tous mes voyages,
j’avais une quête :
la quête du silence.
Le silence m’a permis
d’écouter ma voix intérieure,
celle que j’avais essayé de
faire taire depuis des années.
À travers tous ces voyages,
j’ai découvert que
je suis capable d’être heureuse seule.
Je suis capable de passer
des soirées avec des inconnus,
de pas stresser si mon train est en retard
ou si j’ai nulle part où dormir.
Pour la première fois,
je me sentais vraiment moi-même.
J’avais l’impression
d’être à la bonne place.
Il y avait personne pour me dire :
« Mais t’étais pas comme ça avant. »
« Pour qui tu te prends ? »
J’ai rencontré beaucoup de personnes,
j’ai rencontré beaucoup
de personnes sur mon chemin
qui m’ont aidée à comprendre qui je suis.
J'ai créé des amitiés.
J'en ai perdu.
Parmi toutes les personnes
que je retrouvais,
il y en a avec qui j’ai passé
quelques jours,
d’autres seulement quelques heures
et même quelques minutes.
Et parmi toutes ces personnes,
je me suis rendu compte que
personne n’allait se souvenir de moi.
Et je crois que c'était bon signe.
Et j’ai compris que dans mon quotidien
en France, c’était un peu la même chose.
On est tous concentrés
sur nos propres actions,
mais sans voir celles des autres.
Faites le test : est-ce que vous
vous souvenez de la dernière fois
que par exemple votre meilleure amie
a fait quelque chose de gênant ?
Personnellement, je me souviens pas.
Au quotidien, on braque une caméra sur soi
en pensant que tout le monde voit
la même chose.
Tout le monde voit le même film.
C’est un biais cognitif
qui nous pousse à croire que
on a tous la même image de la vie,
alors que c’est pas le cas.
En vrai, je surestimais l’importance
que les gens me donnaient.
J’étais tétanisée par le
jugement des autres.
Je pensais que les gens
me jugeaient sans cesse.
Et en fait, bah non.
On est tous en réalité inquiets
par nos propres actions.
On est tous en train de s’autojuger.
Et on n’a pas vraiment le temps, l’esprit
pour le faire pour les autres.
Pendant que moi je suis en train de me
demander si je suis assez bonne pour vous,
si vous allez pas voir
mes jambes qui tremblent.
Vous êtes peut-être en train de penser
à votre prochain voyage,
à votre prochain date Tinder
ou, si j’ai un peu de chance, à ce que
cette conférence va vous apporter.
Comprendre que j’avais pas tant
d’importance que ça dans la vie des autres
m’a paradoxalement beaucoup aidée.
Moi qui avais pour quête
de rendre fiers ma famille, mes amis,
j’étais parti six mois et
rien n’avait changé pour eux.
Alors, quand je suis revenue
après ces voyages,
j’ai commencé à enlever
un à un les masques,
à montrer ma vulnérabilité,
à enlever cette image de Mathilde,
la femme forte, sans émotion.
C’est un peu comme ça qu’on m’a élevée,
à ne pas montrer mes émotions,
à toujours être fort, ne pas pleurer.
Et j’ai décidé d’arrêter
d’être cette personne.
Parce que je pense que la vraie force,
c’est d’oser se montrer
sans Photoshop, sans artifices.
Oser montrer sa vulnérabilité.
Combien de fois on n’a pas osé
aller voir cette personne
par peur du refus.
Cette personne qui nous plaisait.
Combien de fois on n’a pas osé lancer
ce podcast, cette chaîne YouTube
ou tout autre projet
par peur du regard des gens.
Ça va paraître assez bateau de dire ça,
mais je crois réellement que
la vie est trop courte
pour jouer à ces jeux.
Est-ce que la vie elle serait pas mieux si
on allait dire à tout le monde
ce qu’on ressent, si on osait faire
ce qu’on voulait sans se demander ?
Parce qu’au fond,
si on ose faire les choses,
qui s’en préoccupe à la suite ?
Il y a quelque chose
que j’aimerais vous partager.
Il y a deux ans comme je disais au début,
j’avais énormément d’anxiété sociale.
C’est-à-dire que j’étais incapable
d’aller, par exemple, à la boulangerie.
Ou passer un coup de fil,
tout ce genre de choses.
Et un jour je me suis dit,
j’en ai marre de vivre cette vie
qui n’est pas intentionnelle,
qui n’est pas la mienne
et j’ai envie de devenir cette personne
que je vois, que j’imagine.
Mais je l’imaginais toujours
dans des années futures, etc.
Et j’ai toujours vu ces personnes
qui venaient sur scène,
qui délivraient des messages
et ça m’a toujours excitée.
Je sentais qu’il y avait quelque chose,
mon cœur battait un peu plus fort.
Je me sentais vibrer quand
je voyais ces personnes.
Et moi, je pensais que la société était
composée de deux types de personnes :
ceux qui font des choses,
ceux qui vont de l’avant
et ceux qui écoutent.
Et aujourd’hui, je suis là pour
vous prouver que c’est pas le cas.
Que vous avez pas besoin
d’influencer dix personnes.
Cent personnes.
Influencer seulement une seule personne
avec votre singularité,
c’est déjà quelque chose d’énorme.
Aujourd’hui, je peux pas vous
donner une méthode parfaite,
la liste complète des choses
que vous devez faire pour
oser être vous-même,
apprendre à être vous-même.
Mais je peux vous  faire réfléchir,
pardon, à quelques questions.
Est-ce que, si personne
ne vous regardait, dans la vie,
est-ce que vous feriez les mêmes choses ?
Est-ce que vous auriez la même vie ?
Est-ce que
vous avez peur,
vous mettez des masques quand
vous êtes avec certaines personnes ?
Et pour finir, j'ai une dernière question.
J’aimerais que ceux
dont la réponse est oui lèvent la main.
Qui, ici, parmi vous, a peur de la mort ?
Vous pouvez lever la main honnêtement.
Il y a deux mois, j'ai vu une citation
qui m'a beaucoup marquée.
Qui disait : ceux qui ont peur de la mort
sont ceux qui n’ont pas vraiment vécu.
Et moi je crois que
quand on se cache sous une tonne
de masques, on ne vit pas vraiment.
Alors, le message que j’aimerais
vous partager aujourd’hui,
c’est d’oser enlever le masque
et bon voyage dans ce chemin infini
de la découverte de soi.